is with maurice ashley
yes he had the white pieces but it felt
like he had the black or the gray pieces
or something
ray uh he came in
all guns blazing with preparation
against you what were your thoughts when
you saw him banging down move after move
after move
uh yeah i wasn't very happy um he
he uh yeah obviously he
out prepared me as usual actually he
usually out prepares me more uh this
time i at least had
kind of some idea of what was happening
and i was white so it was a little bit
easier but yeah obviously
it was very very difficult to play over
the board um yeah already on move four i
played b takes c6 which is not as common
as the mainline takes c6
and then i played d4 cd queen d4 f6 and
here i played queen a4 so i mean i knew
this move
although i couldn't really remember the
idea as much i think queen a4 the idea
is i want to push c4 c5 if possible
quickly and i'm like keeping his c pawn
pinned so for some reason i thought this
was a accurate move order but i didn't
remember anything
you're right exactly the games did go in
that direction the point you were making
yeah and queen b6 queen b6 was novelty
it's i did i didn't know the move i had
no clue if it was a novelty or not uh
but yeah i feel like these positions in
general aren't very
i haven't been played very much anyway
um at least the specific positions yeah
queen b64 yeah i kind of assumed he's
gonna sack the pawn and i calculated
this line um actually here so bishop f5
was my initial idea at some point i was
wondering if actually e5 was his like
preparation uh ede-5 i guess i should
take otherwise his structure improved a
lot so i should take
and then he takes and opens the position
i guess probably the computer says it's
good for me but
since i thought bishop f5 seemed fine i
thought maybe this was his idea but then
he just immediately played bishop f5
bishop d3 queen e6 this is what i
calculated take take and it looks like
i'm doing it fine like i'm going to
develop my knight to c3 bishop e3 knight
d4 and
look like if he wants to take on e6
he'll have to give up his light square
bishop and then you know i could never
be worse at least
a7 is also always a potential weakness
but then he played knight h6 also okay
he spent maybe 30 seconds this time
but yeah knight h6 and then i realized
yeah somehow this knight is just coming
here and the
problem is also in some lines his knight
we can even just go back to g7 and just
to take the pawn
and yeah if he takes this pawn and he
keeps the two bishops then
then he's usually probably just better
and
even if i
maybe exchange off his light square
bishop
let's just say g4 knight g7
knight d4 bishop c4
let's say i played b3 or something and
here to take with the bishop even if i
get this bishop off the board usually it
seemed like i would have to play g4 and
then he always has a hook with h5
and i didn't like my pawn structure on
the king side his king will just go to
f7 and
he has a better pawn structure i thought
even positions like this could be
unpleasant so it was
really
difficult for me to figure out what i
should do because there's lots of
complications and i assume that i'm
should be fine objectively but
um obviously it's very difficult when
your opponent's still in their
preparation so i played knight d5 which
was a logical move castle seemed forced
and now knight before seemed like the
principal continuation and here uh he
went bishop c4 which is logical bishop
e4 was i wasn't sure if it was possible
or not but again he quickly went
bishop c4
um and g4 yeah i spent a lot of time
here because i had one to play g4 and
then after he won bishop c4 i got
worried that g4 maybe he has knight d4
um
and now after we exchange
bishop e3 he takes my g pawn now and
then if he gets my e pawn as well this
is terrible but eventually i realize
after rook c1 king b7
uh i have f3 fortunately
and i was requested to go to h4
and bishop f2 rook f4 and
at minimum i have bishop g3 bishop f2
back maybe i have something maybe i can
play for a win but at least i have
a draw i thought although he has
bishop h6 yes
that was the variation we were
calculating with bishop h6 okay i didn't
notice bishop h6 during the game
although maybe it's still fine there um
but yeah i thought here i'm safe so he
went for knight g7 which is
seemed critical um but the point was
here at least i got to put my bishop on
e3
um which i i thought made more sense
because if i put it on f4 like instead
of g4 i could have played bishop f4
immediately
um
with with or without without g4 without
g4 right so
bishop f4
very logical rook c1 is coming so the
problem is king b7 he just delays taking
the pawn so he can challenge my rook on
the c5 rook c1 or c8
and uh now it's i would like to castle
but i can't um
and so it makes sense to kick the knight
now with g4 i guess
knight g7
and
the problem is he's always either taking
an e6 with tempo or later after he takes
an e6 and moves the piece
off of e6 he's going to play e5 with
tempo on my bishop on f4 so that's why i
thought uh it's better to put the bishop
on e3 if i can that's why i started with
g4
bishop e3 king b7
rook c1
i didn't see
what else to play rook c8 knight d4
takes so yeah i guess somewhere here was
critical maybe
maybe i had something better but during
the game i just didn't i think this
moment
ray after you played bishop e3 i think
we were expecting bishop takes e6
so at least we have a tempo
over here i mean
it's super double edged if you end up
taking this bond and we have
but okay we thought
okay but as it went sorry king b7 here
takes so yeah after bishop g4 um
yeah this seemed like maybe i had some
some better way to continue the attack
here but i just wasn't sure obviously i
i spent uh all my time so maybe
yeah i wasn't sure if i should have
taken an f6 immediately back or if i
should have
tried to keep the rooks i just didn't
see a clear way to attack uh
yeah maybe here i could have played rook
c1 instead of taking on f6 i just wasn't
sure and i didn't want to risk him just
keeping the pawn because now for example
he could play f5 but probably that's
good for me
f5 rook c6 maybe
and now i think the problem is if rook
d8 i have bishop g5 and his rook is uh
overloaded defending both bishops
so it's possible i could have included
rook c1 but um
i just decided to take and be safe
because this can't be so bad but yeah
now he's at least safe himself
and i'm kind of uh on the defensive
so it was it was still very difficult
here
um
yeah i thought all his moves were
logical um
maybe we made some mistakes but during
the game everything seemed
by the way all right we got a decisive
game here with carissa so she did win
the game big comeback for her ray we've
got a lot of interviews lined up so uh
your your thoughts now you had a
are you
more relieved than anything else like
what's your emotion going into
coming right after this game and now
going into tomorrow yeah i mean i'm
definitely relieved going to the game
obviously i wanted to try to win but
during the game
the way it went yeah i just had to
defend and i was in a very difficult
situation
whereas in the previous games i think i
was never worse so it was a lot
different this game
so yeah mostly i'm just happy that i i
got out with half a point before i let
you go
the carolina blue jacket tell us why
this is looks like your favorite jacket
oh i mean it's a great jacket from the
olympiad obviously good memories and i
just don't have a lot of jackets and i
don't like
buying new things often so
yeah that's basically it okay all right
i remember those olympic jackets those
were good memories uh all right well
you're tied for first good luck uh
tomorrow and hope to do more interviews
with you thanks good luck absolutely
ray ray